us the shared experience we would have
all rather avoided of course the smoke
from northern fires continues to hang
over much of Ontario here's a live look
from the global news Chopper and that
tells the tale you can usually see the
skyline from this vantage point but not
today the hazy and unpleasant atmosphere
means air quality advisories remain in
effect Cullen Demello is standing by
with the questions opposition leaders
want the Ford government to answer about
the situation but first shlima maharash
on the impacts the smoke is having on
everyday life right now and this
includes a decision late this afternoon
from the TDSB hello
hi there Anthony that's right we heard
from the TDSB less than an hour ago
confirming to us that they had
re-evaluated and based on the advisory
based on the air quality they've decided
that tomorrow all outdoor activities so
we are talking about recess we're
talking about field trips as well as any
of those athletic events those will be
moved indoors or rescheduled altogether
a decision on Friday is expected to come
on Thursday and when it comes to what
we're dealing with right now that of
course is in large part due to those
massive Wildfire plumes that we are
seeing in Quebec as well as Northeastern
Ontario we've seen the entire gtha just
really a Delta a really big blow in the
sense of thick film of haze that's been
coating the city skyline school boards
across the gtha have been taking some
similar steps to the TDSB announcing
that they will also be going in that
direction the Toronto Blue Jays also
announcing late this afternoon that they
will be keeping the Dome closed for
tonight's game against the Astros now we
had a chance to hear from all of you to
see exactly how you are coping with the
Wildfire Haze
what's your level of concern right now
uh very because my wife and I were
saying that we haven't seen it this bad
and ever across the country so it's it's
very bad and it's only Jew it's
discouraging it's a downer it's uh you
know it's um
it's it's not what you want and now it's
an issue you know becoming an issue
across the country it's not normal I
hope it's going to get back to normal
because it's nice to see The beautiful
landscape of Toronto
um hopefully it's going to get back to
normal soon
now the city is also announced as of
late this afternoon some changes to its
recreational programming such as the
cancellation of some outdoor
recreational programming that took place
today and was scheduled for today and
then also moving some of that
programming indoors where possible so
certainly something to be mindful of as
we continue to deal with the haze
Anthony yeah I know a lot of the track
meets across Ontario affected by this so
hopefully those are rescheduled because
I know these kids have worked very hard
for this salima thank you so much for
this
now if the past few weeks are any
indication this is expected to be a busy
Wildfire season in Ontario already there
are dozens of fires burning across the
province 25 are considered out of
control now the premier today promising
financial support for fire Crews
Global's Queens Park bureau chief Colin
Demello has more on that angle High
Colin
and today Premiere Doug Ford said today
that he acknowledges the major impact
the smoke has been having right across
the greater Toronto and Hamilton area
the premier says firefighting Crews from
both Ontario and Minnesota are currently
in Northern Ontario trying to dampen all
of these Flames but as for the cause of
these fires the premier said today he's
blaming lightning strikes and campers
across Northern Ontario there are 20 000
hectares of land currently Ablaze and an
army of fire Crews on the front lines
fighting the Flames we have 142 fire
Ranger Crews which are the best in the
world ready to go right across our
Province and we have a fleet of 28
aircraft to fight these fires including
nine heavy water bombers Ontario's
situation is already serious enough that
the province is relying on International
Health in fact we have four water
bombers from Minnesota assisting us
right now and and we're thankful for
that but now now the government is
facing the political heat with the
opposition Fanning the Flames people are
quite rightly worried for their
immediate future and whether this is the
new reality critics want the government
to address the root causes of the Raging
wildfires the severity of forest fires
increase because of the dry hot weather
we're facing these fires are directly
related to The Climate crisis when asked
about it initially the minister for
natural resources and Forestry indicated
the forest fires were caused by careless
campers the minister of natural
resources and Forestry refused to
acknowledge a connection between the
climate crisis and these forest fires
does the premier acknowledge that the
climate emergency is making this fire
season significantly worse but the
premier only doubled down approximately
50 percent of the fires are started by
lightning strikes the other 50 percent
are people starting campfires not
putting out the campfires properly they
happen every single year the government
is accusing its critics of politicizing
the issue saying amid the smoke it's the
fire they're worried about for now
so is Ontario actually in a proper
position to be able to fight all of
these wildfires One National agency that
tracks provincial responses to wildfires
questioned whether Ontario actually has
the resources to fight all these Flames
the government says they will spare no
resource to back up the firefighters and
that they can borrow some Crews from
other provinces also fighting wildfires
of their own at quench Park I'm Colin
Demello Anthony back to you Colin thank
you so much